THEIR HEADS.
BRIT HUME, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON PRIME BRET.
>> Brit: YOU BET, JESSE.
>> Jesse: BEN SHAPIRO BEST SIDE
OF HISTORY, SOME SAY BETTER THAN
MY BOOK.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THEM BUT I
WILL LET THAT STAND.
BEN SHAPIRO YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS CASE DEVELOP YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE MEDIA COVERAGE
AND THIS RUN AWAY PROSECUTOR?
>> THE MEDIA COVERAGE HAS BEEN
DISGUSTING FROM BEGINNING TO
END.
IT MIRRORED AN ORIGINAL
NARRATIVE WHICH THAT KYLE
RITTENHOUSE MUST HAVE BEEN SOME
SORT OF WHITE SUPREMACIST TRUMP
SUPPORTER IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RIOTS IN 2020 WHEN WE WERE
LEARNING THAT AMERICA WAS
APPARENTLY BROKEN DOWN INTO TWO
GROUPS.
PEOPLE WHO WANTED RACIAL JUSTICE
AND PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED TRUMP
AND YOU ARE ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER.
THEREFORE IF THERE WERE PEOPLE
RIOTING IN KENOSHA NOT REALLY
RIOTS MOSTLY PEACEFUL PROTESTS
AND ANYBODY OPPOSING THOSE FOLKS
HAD TO BE SOME SORT OF WHITE
SUPREMACIST TRUMP SUPPORTER.
YOU HAD BIDEN FEATURE KYLE
RITTENHOUSE IN AN AD 2020
ALONGSIDE WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
AS IT TURNS OUT NONE OF THE
SPHACKETS REFLECT THAT ONLY
PEOPLE THAT GOT SHOT HERE WERE
WHITE.
PEOPLE ATTACKING THEM AT LEAST
ONE OF THEM WAS A CONVICTED
CHILD MOLESTER.
ANOTHER ONE OF THEM A CONVICTED
CRIMINAL AND ALL THREE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE SHOT BY KYLE
RITTENHOUSE WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF ANN TACKING HIM BY ALL
WITNESS, FORENSIC AND VIDEO
EVIDENCE.
THE MEDIA COMPLETELY BOTCHED
THIS ONE.
IT'S ONCE MORE OF REINFORCEMENT
OF THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA ARE A
BUNCH OF LYING HACKS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PROPAGANDA FOR
A LIVING.
>> Jesse: I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
YOU MENTIONED I GUESS IT WAS TOO
COMPLEX FOR THE MEDIA TO WRAP
THEIR HEAD AROUND THE FACTS THAT
THERE ARE WHITE AMERICANS THAT
WANT RACIAL JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY, WANT THE LAWS FOLLOWED,
WANT POLICE TO CONDUCT
THEMSELVES HONORABLY.
BUT, ALSO, DON'T WANT THEIR OWN
HOMETOWNS LOOTED AND RANSACKED.
THEY COULDN'T REALLY PROCESS
THAT WHAT THEY DID, AS YOU
MENTIONED, THEY TAKE A CONVICTED
PEDOPHILE, A LYING COMMUNIST.
A GUY WHO SLAPPED HIS OWN
GRANDMOTHER WITH AN OPEN HAND
AND MADE THESE GUYS INTO HEROES.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO YOU ABOUT
THE PRESS IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
THOSE GUYS ARE THE HEROES IN
THEIR PLOT LINE?
>> AND THE NARRATIVE MATTERS
MUCH MORE THAN THE FACTS.
HOW MANY STORIES DO WE HAVE TO
SEE THEM BOTCH IN ONE DIRECTION
BEFORE WE DECIDE THEY ARE
PROPAGANDIST.
EVERYTHING FROM JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH TO THE COVINGTON
CATHOLIC CASE TO JULIETTE TO JUE
SMOLLETT.
THE THING SO TROUBLING ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR CASE OBVIOUSLY
NOT EVEN THE PRESS THE FACT THAT
THE PROSECUTOR WAS SO CUD GEL IN
THE PRESS HE DECIDED TO BRING
CASE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
NO EVIDENCE NOT SELF-DEFENSE
NEGATIVE EVIDENCE.
HIS OWN WITNESSES WERE
TESTIFYING AGAINST THE
PROSECUTION'S POSITION.
WHY HE THOUGHT THAT HE COULD
BRING THIS CASE IS BEYOND ME
UNLESS YOU JUST BELIEVE THAT HE
WAS DOING IT FOR THE MEDIA AND
SEE IF IT WORKS OUT FOR HIM.
>> Jesse: THERE HE IS YOU SEE ON
THE SCREEN POINTING AN AR-15 AT
THE JURY WITH HIS FINGER
ACTUALLY ON THE TRIGGER.
IT'S JUST ASTOUNDING THAT
SOMEONE LIKE THAT HOLDS OFFICE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE IS ALSO SOME SNOBBERY AT
PLAY.
I BROUGHT THIS UP EARLIER ON OUR
AIR.
THE PRESS DOESN'T THINK KENOSHA
AS A MIDWESTERN TOWN IS WORTHY
OF PROTECTING.
THEY DON'T THINK KYLE
RITTENHOUSE SHOULD BE OUT THERE
PROTECTING SOME STUPID, YOU
KNOW, CAR DEALERSHIP, THIS IS
FLYOVER COUNTRY.
RIGHT?
THIS ISN'T WORTH -- THIS ISN'T
LIKE THE HAMPTONS GETTING
LOOTED.
THIS ISN'T GEORGETOWN.
THIS IS SMALL TOWN AMERICA.
WHO CARES IF IT BURNS?
YOU CAN ALWAYS, YOU KNOW, BUY
ANOTHER CAR DEALERSHIP.
AND THAT SNOBBERY REALLY THEIR
ENTIRE POSTURE THROUGHOUT ALL OF
THE RIOTS.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE THING TO REMEMBER ABOUT THIS
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THEY'RE ANGRY
AT KYLE RITTENHOUSE FOR SHOWING
UP IN ORDER TO DEFEND PRIVATE
PROPERTY AND BUSINESSES.
THEY'RE ANGRY THAT THE COPS WERE
LED.
LED ALL THIS OFF IN KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN, THEY DECIDED TO
MALIGN INNOCENT COPS.
THEY DECIDED JACOB BLAKE WAS
SHOT UNJUSTIFIABLY.
TURNED OUT JACOB BLAKE HAD
ARREST WARRANT OUT FOR HIM
ALLEGED THIRD DEGREE SEXUAL
ASSAULT HE REFUSED TO TURN
HIMSELF OVER TO THE COPS AND
CARRYING A KNIFE GOT HIMSELF
SHOT IN THE PROCESS.
NOT ONLY THE MEDIA PLAYED THAT
AS ANOTHER STAIN ON AMERICA'S
RACIALLY CHARGED SYSTEM, BUT JOE
BIDEN CALLED UP JACOB BLAKE,
KAMALA HARRIS VISITED WITH THE
FAMILY.
THIS WAS ALL PART OF THE BROADER
NARRATIVE WHICH IS THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM IS RACIST, ROOT.
THAT MEANS THAT ROOT AND BRANCH
THAT MEANS ANYBODY WHO DEFENDS
ANY INSTITUTION INCLUDING I
GUESS THE CAR DEALERSHIP IS PART
OF THAT.
>> Jesse: THEY CREATED RACIAL
RIOTS WITH DECEPTION ON THE
BLAKE CASE AND THEN WHEN THE
VACUUM OF POWER WAS FILLED BY
RIOTERS AND BY DO GOODERS TWO
PEOPLE WERE SHOT DEAD.
AND NOW THEY WANT THE GUY WHO
WAS THERE TO DEFEND THE
COMMUNITY BASICALLY THEY WANT
HIS LIFE TO BE OVER.
AND HAVE HIM ROT IN PRISON
FOREVER.
AND THEY WANT TO LINE NICE THE E
DOMESTIC PREDATOR.
YOU IT'S DISGUSTING.
MSNBC CUT THIS UP AND SPLICE
THIS UP AS MASQUERADE IT INTO
SOMETHING IT'S NOT.
DAILY WIRE STRAIGHT DOWN THE
MIDDLE COVERAGE, BROADCASTING
THE ENTIRE TRIAL.
LET THE AUDIENCE DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY CAN HEAR THE VIDEO AND LOOK
AT THE TESTIMONY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET THE TRUTH.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE SPIN.
LAST WORD BEN SHAPIRO.
>> I ALWAYS CONTRIBUTE TO
STUPIDITY AND MALICE WHEN I CAN.
IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO WATCH THE
PROSECUTOR IN THIS CASE AND
THINK IT'S MALICE RATHER THAN
STUPIDITY.
>> Jesse: LET'S SPRINKLE IN A